سنأخذك إلى Fort Myers Florida ،
ما ننظر إليه هو لقطة حية لطائرة بدون طيار CNN ،
سنعرض لك
بعضًا مما رأيناه تمامًا كما
تمكنا من النهوض فوق
المنطقة  لإلقاء نظرة فقط على
الدمار الذي تراه
هناك ، أعني أن لديك حطامًا في
كل مكان ، الماء والماء والمزيد من
أسطح المياه تقشر
بشكل عشوائي ، ونرى
أيضًا كلما اقتربت من الشاطئ حيث يمكنك رؤية
الخط الساحلي  إلى يمينك ، يمكنك أن ترى
أنها مجرد قوارب تم رميها في كل
مكان ، فقط انظر إلى الأشجار
الممزقة
بينما تستمر هذه الطائرة بدون طيار من خلال
إظهار بعض
الدمار الذي تم وصفه
لنا مرارًا وتكرارًا
نحن نعلم أن العديد من عمليات الإنقاذ كانت
مطلوبة ، فنحن نتحدث فقط إلى خفر
السواحل وأنهم يقومون
بإنقاذ من الهواء والماء للأشخاص الذين يحتاجون إلى
إنقاذهم من أسطح منازلهم
مما كانوا يتعاملون معه  مع ويمكنك أن
ترى وأنت الآمر  نأمل أن يكون الكثير من
هذه العائلات قد خرجوا إلى أرض أكثر أمانًا
ووصلوا إلى الأرض المرتفعة بالطبع نظرًا لأن
هذه العاصفة كانت تنطلق عبر تلك
الشوارع التي لا تزال مغطاة بالمياه ، فقد رأينا
صورة أخرى لقطة أخرى كانت
الطائرة بدون طيار قد التقطتها قبل لحظات من القوارب التي
انقلبت.  حول أن تبدو مثل
الألعاب أكثر من مئات الآلاف من
الدولارات من القوارب الجميلة التي تمزقت الأرصفة للتو